guys you're never going to believe this
we are on an emergency mission because
the snap bought snapchat spectacles
bought is now set up in Santa Monica
Jenna texted me said guess what it's at
the pier I hopped in my car I am driving
not very fast because you can't really
drive very fast in Santa Monica Jenna is
on her way we are going to get ourselves
some snapchat spectacles I already have
a pair but I love them so much that I'm
getting them for the Pittsburgh Penguins
because they tweeted me the day that I
got them and asked if I could get them
an extra pair so I'm doing this for the
Pittsburgh Penguins and because Jenna
doesn't have them and a bunch of my
friends don't have them yet and honestly
they're so cool I was skeptical of the
spectacles but I am a skeptic no more
after using them they're pretty awesome
so let's go to the pier hope the line
isn't too long and see what we can see
oh my goodness I need it down here so
quickly
as quick as my little wheels could spin
and there is an absolutely massive line
Jenna's on our way I'm a little bit
nervous because I don't know I'm
actually gonna be able to get these
things but I did pack a snack and I know
how to camp out on a quick turn of a
dime and we're here there it is
crap these line goes all ok doubt I'm
not sure this is gonna be oh my god holy
crap there's so many people here
hello how are you so late
okay I hate we got same like my sister
texted me I was like I just woke up
I know oh my goodness this is insane
what have you got here so these are
tattoos temporary that are tweets and
this is from Justin Bieber and it says
like I said Love Wins and I also got
some DJ Khaled but I saw that yeah
Justin Bieber ones and there was like is
there any way I could have one of those
Twitter tats calm awesome okay this is
amazing i'ma put these on later thank
you
yeah yeah awesome yeah nice to meet you
too
hi oh my goodness oh my goodness oh boy
this what coffee all over myself and
animals got a car accident a sweet dog
how are you I missed you
okay we've got really really bad news
they said that they're not going to
restock it and they're all out but
there's so many people here
their offices in Venice it's super close
like I could just I could just go get
some more and put them in the Bott
really nearly 70 people it's really
close oh I think I'm gonna I'm gonna
wait a little bit longer
what do we do we just gonna get food let
me cry into our omelets I'm always into
crying into omelets
and you want to go crying for omelet the
little tears came so fast Oh a preffered
everybody kind of help you guys out a
little bit fix me to get back in line
sorry I have to leave by like 11 or okay
all right let's get back in line okay I
hope I hope that our line mates will
accept us back just the two seconds ago
that I wasn't gonna get back in line and
Here I am getting back in line I'm doing
it for the Pittsburgh Penguins okay
we're officially leaving no this is just
really sad before snapchat BAM right
that's right ah terrible so many sad
people there was like this little kid in
the shark costume and he's like it was
my birthday I came here he's like I've
never been so up covered by the way
Steve Jobs Oprah thank you yeah okay bye
five thank you
I've given up well trying to eat the
snapchat spectacles was quite a
spectacle at least like at Apple when
they didn't have any iPhones they let
people know and said it's fine you can
go they were telling other people to
just go tell people in line but like we
don't know if we should believe the
people or not I had to leave it because
I've got to go do some work and edit and
I have a shoot later today so I
unfortunately couldn't say that's it for
this video I this was just a random
little snapchat adventure I'm so sorry
to the Pittsburgh Penguins because I was
doing this for you guys I really wanted
them to get the specs but Noel's back at
least I met a lot of really cool people
that's one of the things that I will say
that when you're waiting in lines for
something no matter what it is you're
gonna meet a lot of like-minded people
because everybody is essentially waiting
for the same thing and clearly you're
waiting for something that means a lot
to you or you wouldn't be waiting I
think I said by like four times this
video
so here we go this is the official
unboxing basically the only way to get
these is through a vending machine
called a smart bond yeah a snap bot so
these are supposed to I really actually
don't know what they're gonna do so here
we are
have you done an unboxing no I don't
even know what to do I feel like I
apologize please forgive me because this
is my first